there's a great anecdote about the very
first photograph taken of Earth from the
vantage point of space the idea was that
this photograph occasioned a profound
shift in our understanding of ourselves
you see for the first time in human
history we could look back at our planet
in its entirety and see the big picture
this provided an ontological awakening
it changed our story our narrative it
upgraded our self image it expanded our
consciousness new maps for new realities
as they said astronauts in orbit call
this experience the overview effect a
boundary shattering sense of Revelation
and global interconnectedness where we
shake off our petty differences and
emerge with a sense of global
responsibility global consciousness and
global citizenship Carl Sagan's famous
pale blue dot film echoed this same idea
from the vantage point of space there
are no lines dividing nations no
geographical subdivisions no flags or
racial divides or disputed territory
there is only earth a single celestial
body teeming with life the womb in which
we dwell
yet the fact is our historically myopic
point of view most certainly our limited
perspective has resulted in much
animosity we have all too often
organized ourselves into competing
hostile tribes subjugating each other
for land and resources and
misrepresenting the big picture into a
story of borders subdivisions and
dividing lines too much hostility not
enough empathy and compassion cultural
differences religion tribes nation race
these are creative expressions and
variations that should and could be
celebrated instead they become symbols
that are all too often used to create
suffocating boundaries and they are
increasingly ill-conceived to address
the challenges of a hyper-connected
global world as advancements in
technology and information enable
greater mobility of ideas goods and
people the role of the physical border
is shifting and doofer in public
conflicts remain and too many people are
restricted access to the increasingly
fluid means of migration transportation
and movement migration has always been a
defining factor of the human experience
migration has and continues to touch all
nations cultures and regions all peoples
on the planet
migration has been the seed at the heart
of thriving societies accelerating the
dissemination of knowledge and ideas
restricting migration is ultimately like
restricting the flow of ideas in much
the same way that we don't tolerate
censorship or book-burning we might
consider the ways in which restricting
the free movement of people can be
equally punishing to the idea of human
flourishing the desire to become a
global citizen is human we all have it
and we all share the same goals for
safety comfort and prosperity for our
family
some are fortunate enough to be able to
invest in a second residence and
citizenship while others are forced to
seek asylum for their survival being a
global citizen is also about the strong
and the wealthy helping the weak in the
poor as we saw with the global citizen
tax initiative border disputes conflict
zones armed borders these are things
that persist and need to be addressed we
need a new story a new lens with which
to address these inconsistencies we need
to scale up to unleash a truly global
citizenry exchanging ideas beliefs goods
and services it has been said that
empathy rarely extends beyond our line
of sight and so perhaps it is by
extending our gaze using marvelous new
storytelling tools like virtual reality
that we can bridge divisions and bring
worlds together assuring in a form of
radical empathy to see the other as
ourselves where boundaries are dissolved
compassion reigns supreme massive
transformation of consciousness a
software upgrade for mankind
birthing a new kind of global citizen we
can do this